centro del grupo militar Wagner se lee
en el cartel se trata de la nueva y
deslumbrante sede de lo que hasta hace
poco Era uno de los grupos paramilitares
rusos más ocultos del mundo en su
inauguración el viernes el centro de
varias plantas en San petesburgo fue
anunciado como un espacio creativo para
las empresas patrióticas que quieren
Apoyar el sector de la defensa de Rusia
el edificio fue construida experiencias
privadas y está preparado para ofrecer
espacio gratuito a los blogueros
diseñadores ingenieros y creativos que
tienen un objetivo y una tarea hacer que
nuestro hermoso país sea aún mejor
pero detrás de esta reluciente fachada
Los mercenarios del grupo Wagner han
sido acusados de crímenes de guerra en
varios países de África y en Siria y
recientemente en Ucrania donde cada vez
se ha visto más involucrado los críticos
lo ven como una fuerza en la sombra del
kremlin utilizada para promover los
intereses rusos en el extranjero
proporcionando combatientes y asesores
el gobierno ruso siempre ha negado
cualquier vínculo Pero el mes pasado un
oligarca y Aliado de Vladimir Putin Y
precushin puso fin a años de rumores
cuando admitió que estaba detrás del
grupo no hubo rastro del multimillonario
en la inauguración del centro que al
parecer financió personalmente
es probablemente la única persona en
Rusia que ahora habla abiertamente con
retórica patriótica y no duda en decir
abiertamente que da su dinero personal a
la operación especial de Ucrania los
analistas afirman que el centro Wagner
se considera un paso más de priegos para
adoptar un papel más público en la
configuración de la política de defensa
de Rusia desde que se presentó como
fundador del grupo en este video de
movimiento de prisioneros para la Guerra
de Ucrania ha criticado cada vez más
abiertamente la actuación de los
generales rusos en la guerra contra el
país vecino